thank you alejandro yes i'm here
with wesley so wesley a very interesting
game it looked at some point we could
find some imbalances
but it wasn't meant to be how did it
feel from your perspective
uh well again thanks for having me here
and i just think that with chess club
alexander alpha the author uh maurice
and maurice of course uh who else is
there jennifer thank you
arnold maurice alejandro and yasser and
yeah are in the studio
yes hello everyone saint louis and i'm
very excited to play in st
louis in a month or so but anyway this
game
um yeah first of all
uh maximus on our operator but he knows
it very well
so i thought i'd try e4
knight before but he's played this line
before h4
and here knight c6 is one of the main
lines but maxine plays knight d4 knight
b5
and he played this four years ago where
he played bishop e6
which was not as good but obviously
maxim
knows it very well it looks quite
unnatural right this
whole variation with the knight moving
all the way from g8
to c6 after like a million moves yeah
definitely
the knight moves here in fact i can even
play knight b3 here so if a beginner
sees this game
he's going to be like am i supposed to
play chess like this what is the
background today yeah he had that
true well the problem is the engines
show a lot of ideas like knight d3 is a
modern move for example
knight e6 has been played before in the
old days i think even
60 years ago or 50 years ago
if i remember correctly i think gary
analyzed some lines
with this for black well the reason is
that e4 weakens
the d4 and d3 squares so after
e4 the lines become very forcing but
basically black is super behind in
development so that's why he has to give
a check
in order not to allow the white king to
castle and in return uh
for the lack of development he gets this
weakness on the default more or less at
least momentarily and also
the lack of a possibility to castle yeah
that's true so i guess
white does tremendously but the d5 d4 d3
squares are vulnerable
and this position looks very very shaky
for black but it also has been analyzed
numerous times in old books i've read
this before
also modern engines don't really give
much for white for example
i mean it looks very risky for black but
for example play like b4
to sacrifice a pawn to gain the center
black doesn't
even take the pawn he just plays g6 wow
the idea to develop the bishop to get
dark's worse yeah
yes so this knife is very complex but
obviously maxim knows it very well i
thought
i could surprise him with h4 but he
clearly knew all the best moves also
like 96 is a very good move
it seems like he more or less knew all
the way until
let's say even bishop takes h4 he played
it quite quickly
were you surprised at this point were
you still in your preparation
yeah i had some ideas like this but i
was hoping he wouldn't know it this far
but unfortunately he knew the line very
well i think
after queen here on move 13 like a
several moves too such as
e5 or g6 but i guess e6 is simple enough
here black can also play bishop d7
take stakes but maybe white has more
chances of an advantage here with rook
d1 coming
i guess bishop e7 this position looks
quite risky for black because i can
always double his pawns
but maxim knew it very well and he
clearly was
quite happy with the position i mean i
could
take and then and then my queen
looks quite passive on e1 after rook g3
yeah this is still his preparation
obviously bishop takes
because if he plays king h8 then
yeah now i could take and then play some
e5 later yeah it seems like black is
starting to struggle on the king's side
and bishop is dead
yeah after all let's in the
justification bishop takes h4 by the way
i just want to show that group g4
doesn't work because after bishop f65
black of knight takes
and there's a chuckling d1 and gravity
and 21 queen takes g4
and that's the main reason why this
entire one one grabbing works
and at some point things uh we were
discussing here in the studio
and we were mentioning that maybe the
idea could be to play something along
the lines that we should be to try
together
with c3 on the long diagonal did you
consider this yeah that's true that was
probably
what i prepared but i mixed up the move
board yeah i think i prepared this line
bishop d2
the thing is like after king g1 i
thought
he was going to play e5 anyway and then
maybe i could get an improved version by
playing a4
now he can play okay four but i was
thinking so long and after king g1 rook
a4 i miscalculated something
i think i miscalculated that after takes
rook b8
quincy took windy four oh this is the
main thing i forgot i forgot he has
queen
over here yeah i thought he had to play
king h8 king h8 i think
i'm very slightly better but
i just totally forgot that he could play
right away queen rookie
24 and in addition after queen takes
physics i think
i also miss that black has this queen e5
idea and that's going to be a checkmate
yup
our winning material yeah so those are
the lines i missed but
basically i knew i was supposed to play
some bishop d2
but then i thought i could get improved
version for example maybe i could play
a42
i think a4 was interesting but rook d8
doesn't allow you to go bishop d2
um the position keeps being balanced at
this point i don't think you missed too
many things
neither did he yeah so basically i had
to play
bishop d2 i think this was maybe the
only chance to kind of destabilize the
position
nevertheless it's still very close to
equality i think and after that
the queens were traded uh it seemed
pretty smooth
going towards the draw yeah then i think
here i mean
maybe max theme has
uh last chance with rook d5 or something
but i mean it's still a draw it's a
troll yeah yeah yeah
takes if five repeats and
everything gets traded off you're
playing uh lupulus
with the black pieces tomorrow uh he's
uh obviously not doing very well
are you going to uh take any extra
chances with the black pieces or
keep it uh keep it tight uh i'm not sure
well
obviously i have a moral i have to try
to try to catch
the leader yeah i mean today he drew
which was very good decisions obviously
i think the first words have to try like
wrist choke or others
have to try but we'll see what happens
again i just want to play
very well i mean i was really hoping
today to put some pressure you were
definitely putting some pressure at some
point but also your opponent got
quite uh he he knew what he was doing
yeah he knew what he was doing thank you
yeah thanks for kind of i think if i
play bishop d2 here
i mean the position is still equal and
maximus illness preparation so i didn't
really miss much
wisely we're looking forward to see what
you're going to produce tomorrow
and finish strong thank you thank you so
much guys back to you